あ、あ。
う、うん。
ちょっと風邪ぎみです。
最近の動画はめちゃくちゃなことが多いから
今日はちょっとのんびりいきましょう。
ねっ。
こんにちは！！はじめしゃちょーです！！
だーたーたー！
はっ！はっ！はっ！
ははははははははははははははははは！！
(ガタン)
うーーー！
くそー！なんでいつも暴れちまうんだ！
すみません
ちょっと風邪気味なんで
ごほんごほん
今日はのんびり行きましょう
今日はちょっとすごい興味深いものを見つけました
こちら！
（ヒューマンビートボックス）
プルリュリュリュリュ　ビャーー
ーーォ
ドラゴンゲイル　＆　バーストフェネクシオン
君たちは！
ミニ四駆やったことあるかい？
ミニ四駆っていうね～なんかこう、
車のおもちゃがあって、
実際に作ってすごいスピードで走る
おもちゃなんですけどぉ～
で、なんかね、いまもね再ブームが来てるみたいで、
僕もよく遊戯王カードしにね、そういうお店に行くんですけど
結構ミニ四駆やってる人多くて
ちょっとびっくりしてます・・・
それの現代版みたいな感じかな
ちょっとよくわかんないんですけど
買ってしまいました。
これ、僕の好きなタイプですね
ドラゴンゲイル
白青ってなんかこう清潔感があっていいんすよね
ドラゴンゲイルと
この二つを買ってみました
たぶん今の子どもたちにとってのミニ四駆はこれなのかもしれない
僕ね、なんかそういうホ、ホビー系はすごい好きで、
クラッシュギアもやってたしベイブレードもやってた
ビーダマンもやってた
結構そういうおもちゃは昔からずっとやってて
ベーックシュン！！！！
ゲイドライヴもすごい楽しそうだなと思ったんで
買ってみました
とりあえずこの
ドラゴンゲイルとバーストフェネクシオン
作ってみましょう！
ああ、よかった
壊れてなかった・・・
このビニールすごいよ！めっちゃ固いのに
ア゛ァ！！！！
早速、作ってみましょう！
わあ！うぅお～！
なんかシンプルっすね！ゲキドライヴ
すっげーシンプルです！
うわっ！はやっ！
早速、ぼくちゃんのゲキドライヴ
ドラゴンゲイルのライバル
バーストフェニクシオンを作ってあげましょう！
はい！というわけで無事ライバルも完成しました！
これが僕のマシン！
そしてこれが相手！
普通に地面を走らせても全然ブーブーで面白くないんで
なんと！な～んとですね～！
この、ゲキドライヴ用のレーシング場を買ってきました！
こちら！
俺、マジ俺ちょっとね～何を考えたか高まっちゃってさ～
こちら！ゲキドライヴ用のレース場マスタースピードウェイでございます。
よかったなお前ら！
これでいつでも走れるんだぞ
うわうわ面倒くさそう・・・
絶対面倒くせーやつだ・・・
今、朝の4時なんだよね・・・
やるしかねえ！
あっ、おっおおお　おぉぉおお
あぁぁぁあああああ
もう、やだぁぁあ
はい！ひとまずステージ完成しました！
俺の
爆、爆　　　名前忘れた・・・
ゲキドライヴ！
俺のゲキドライヴ人生がいよいよ始まります！
さあ、果たしてこのゲキドライヴはミニ四駆とどれだけ違う動きを見せるのか？
まず一回俺のこいつだけ走らせてみよう！
じゃあちょっと走らせてみます！
３，２，１
なんで逆走しちゃうわけ？
はい！いまので分かったでしょうか？めちゃくちゃ速いです
爆ライダー・・・違うわ　全然名前が違う・・・
ゲキドライヴ全然速いです！
じゃあ次は実際にこの2台で、ちょっと戦わせてみましょう！
どんな感じになるのか、全然想像もつかないからね！
では、バトルさせてみましょう！
３，２，１
ファイヤー！
うわああああ！！！
♪～
友達）なにしてん・・・
ゲキドライヴ